foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm George
Campbell joined by my good friend and
fellow Ramsay personality and fellow
co-host of smart money happy hour Rachel
Cruz and we are here for you America to
help you take that right next step with
your life and your money the number to
call is triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five are you ready
Rachel oh yeah it's pretty rare we get
to host together I know it doesn't
happen very often a momentous occasion
usually with Jade and Christina it's
usually like the girl power I know I
bring enough girl power to the mix let's
be honest there's enough there's enough
there George we're gonna have a good
time all right let's start with Dane and
Lancaster Pennsylvania Dane welcome to
the show how are you doing
how are you guys doing great how can we
help today
um I was just calling for some Financial
advice or kind of what uh you would do
if you were in my situation
so I bought a home about
um six months ago not seven months ago
and a month after I bought my home I got
laid off from my full-time job
so I kind of I used all my savings
to purchase a home which I should have
saved up more but I didn't
um I got a really good deal on the house
at least but
back to my point I lost the job and I
didn't have any savings so I got like
behind on the mortgage
a month after making my first mortgage
payment
um luckily I got a new job that pays a
lot more than my old job but I literally
it's construction so we had work
um the first month and then we were all
for a month and a half and we had a
little bit more work and now we uh now
we have a full schedule for the rest of
the year so
wanted to know what you guys would do if
you were in my situation
because I'm three to four I guess this
is a fourth month I'm behind now so you
just haven't been making a mortgage
payment for four months yeah I haven't
had any money to I just had little a
little bit of work here and there to uh
pay utilities and all that so all that's
good so you're keeping the lights on has
the mortgage lender contacted you
uh no not yet I actually contacted them
and they said they don't really have any
options because we're not I'm not at a
foreclosure yet I guess it takes six
months yeah
so you're you're are you are you three
or four months behind on the mortgage
this is the fourth month this is the
fourth month okay and how much is the
mortgage payment
only thirteen hundred okay and how much
are you bringing in a month or will you
uh this month in March so I'm uh 10.99
and I make uh 13.50 a week straight
check okay um so do you have to put
aside taxes starting now yeah around 300
a week but April 1st two good things
April 1st I am getting a huge pay
increase to 1800 a week and I also got a
second job that will second job on the
weekends that we'll be bringing roughly
like uh 350 bucks extra week so I have a
really good income coming I just need to
play catch-up yeah but I didn't know if
there's a program or something for FHA
guys
like who who have fhas on their home or
what exactly I should do I need to build
a savings that I need to get call back
call back up on my mortgage so yeah so
before the savings even what need the
priority is this mortgage because if you
continue just to get behind which I know
you're not now you're gonna be you're
gonna be able to pay next month's
mortgage payment but four months behind
and so we always say catch up on your
bills your four walls food shelter
utilities and transportation and your
your housing your shelter in that sense
is behind so we before even getting a
savings I mean this is this is catching
up this is go time I mean and I would
even say too I don't know how late you
work at night but like like this is a
little bit of a of a crisis type
situation right like I know going
forward it's fixed with a great income
but you want this you want this out of
your record like you want to be able to
be free from this so I mean this is for
me working Uber at night I mean after
your work I mean this is doing
everything possible this is and then
living on absolutely nothing because
you'll be bringing in I mean right I
think I mean it's going to be close to
eight Grands with the new raise and then
the extra money I'm guessing your tax
your tax withholdings will have to
increase to about 500 bucks a month or
so
at about uh 400 so April first week of
April will be 1800 from the construction
job and my Tax Advisor said to put uh
400 aside in a bank account okay like in
a business account or something so
you're true take home will be about 1400
a week
so 350 1800 still because of the
part-time job awesome okay well that
that gives me a lot of hope so the
really the Gap right now is we got to
cover the five grand we owe to the
mortgage lender so I would contact them
and figure out what this repayment plan
looks like when it's due how we can do
this so that you avoid a foreclosure and
have that communication in writing from
them
I did give them
and try
I get paid today actually
um so I'll actually have like 1800
today and I tried calling to make a
payment and they won't even ex I don't
know what's like with the mortgage
company but they won't even accept a
thousand dollar payment you know
that he all wanted up front because it's
so long past due so they want the entire
amount up front so if it's five grand
they want five grand at once
yeah with fees and everything it's like
6200 so that's our magic number and like
Rachel said our goal is in the next you
know 30 days whatever that looks like to
come up with that six grand
yeah
which means we are not spending a dime
elsewhere other than keeping the lights
on having some food on the table and
getting this mortgage back on track
yep that's the only there's no life hack
I don't think there's any special plans
you can Google they're all going to be
traps the only way to get out of this is
to pay it off yeah and making sure that
you have that in writing and to know
like that it's not that it's not
changing like make that like make this a
locked in
200 and then you know give them even a
date because I mean I would want to be
as proactive as possible because I'm
like I don't want them to turn on me and
do something crazy where I'm like oh my
gosh no no I thought we were fine and so
making sure that everything is in
writing that's going to be really really
important man the thing the thing that
stinks is the longer I wait the more
like just behind I'm gonna get so I
guess there's three I forget three or
four weeks left of March so next month
it's gonna go up to 75 7 600 so with the
penalties
with the penalties or just because you
have a mortgage payment on top of your
of what you have mortgage payment okay
so yeah so stay current so mine would be
I don't want you to get further behind
saving up for behind payments so I would
be paying currently making sure that
that's paid and then saving to get to
this 6200. yeah sell whatever you have
to sell work however much you have to
work do whatever it takes to get back on
track and get that deadline from them
and when that amount is due in full
without incurring any more penalties ugh
I'm so sorry Dane this is where we tell
people man don't jump into a house
before you're ready because it can cause
a lot of issues I'm sorry you're going
through this man but hoping you can get
back on track real soon this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com now
and save up to 50 percent off everything
site-wide visit blinds.com today to
learn more
[Music]
thank you
I'm George Campbell joined by Rachel
Cruz this hour this is the Ramsay show
open phones at AAA
825-5225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money Gabe has chosen
to do so in Burlington Vermont Gabe
welcome to the show how you doing
hey guys how you doing we're doing great
how can we help
so I'm 21 years old I'm still a college
student I got about a year left I've
paid off everything so far and I'm
currently debt free
um and I'm on track to be able to pay
off this last year every semester as
things go just cash flow
exactly nice
um I I also am in a relationship
um and have been pretty intense on
saving up living pretty uh frugally for
the last um
like year or two
um almost maybe too much and I've
realized you know I I've just been
listening to you guys been talking you
know and I've been all about the
intensity of the first two steps but it
sounds like after that things switch
from intensity to intentionality
and I've you know recently just tried to
pick up a third job to make a little bit
extra cash to do things like take my
girlfriend out for dinner and just do
those type of extra things that I
currently there or previously before
that third job couldn't really put any
money anywhere else
um and I guess I'm just wondering if if
even that is the best move with me being
at baby step three should I just be you
know even with that third job making the
money that I'm making there and throwing
it into a savings account to to get
myself through step three as fast as
possible or I I it's kind of almost a
relational advice that I'm asking
um has your girlfriend brought any of
this up
on as far as me doing taking the third
job or not well as far as going hey we
never go on dates and you never want to
spend a dime and we can't do anything no
she wouldn't say anything like that so
so she's cool with all this she's nicer
than me she's not she's not struggling
like me out to dinner that's what I'm
wondering is she reaping any of the uh
you know what you're selling here with
all these jobs yeah and Gabe I mean you
guys are you're in school is she a
senior as well
no she's been she's four years older
than me so she's graduated um okay I
think two three years ago okay that's
great that's great all right and I and
just so I have this clear the two jobs
you have that is basically going for you
to live off of intuition correct it
bills and saving up towards that tuition
okay okay and then you're looking for
baby step three how much do you have
saved
curly
um this last bit of after this tuition
this next tuition has paid off about
about a thousand two thousand dollars
okay two thousand yep that's right well
I currently have a thousand is for my
safety net there's a baby's number one
yeah but you know beyond that I have one
or two okay okay that's great and how
much would a three-month emergency fund
be for you because I mean I feel like
that's all you would need at this stage
of Life uh is more on that three to four
months so how much more of that two
thousand five hundred is what I need to
get to 10 500. that's a pretty that's a
sizable emergency fund for you what kind
of expenses do you have
say say it again what kind of expenses
do you have right now while in school
clearly I'm I'm paying rent
um and I uh have gas you know you need
to pay a little bit of gas to get to
work
um I have a phone bill uh I have uh an
internet bill and in uh car insurance
okay I mean three grand a month yeah
okay so 9 10 grand will get you there
that feels right so how much longer
would it take while working these three
jobs to get there if you were really
focused well if I get through tuition
that's kind of my biggest thing is all
all of that saving money has just been I
know that expense is coming every
semester I want to stay out of debt so
I've been using just everything that I
make that goes into savings it's getting
used to cash flow that tuition
um after that's all done I could
probably get that in a year
okay especially if I held this through
this third job
and so you're not out of the woods yet
as far as intends to intentionality
through baby step three we have to
remain intense and because what we don't
want is I thought it was just one and
two that were intensity yeah you'd carry
that through once you get to baby step
four we can pump the brakes a little bit
and our three job sustainable Gabe for
you
um well currently I'm doing that and
schools a lot and dating yeah I'm doing
32 hours at my job as a cook I'm doing
about 10 hours as a part-time work with
my church okay and then I'm trying to
doordash that's the third job okay
that's great I've been doing that late
evenings
um yeah and you know what okay yeah
burnt out I don't feel like I'm really
fighting anything like that that's great
I think that's awesome because honestly
the time to sacrifice like you're kind
of at the perfect season like I know
everyone's like college enjoy your life
but I mean I mean yeah I was gonna say
like you're you're a senior you know
what you want and you obviously have
goals and this would be the time to be
like oh yeah I'll sacrifice and like do
that because once you once you graduate
and you get a job and you're actually
making an Inca a steady income obviously
you're making great money now but uh
there's just something about being able
to be like oh yeah I'm like already
ready to invest save up a down payment
maybe for a house and like you get to
move on to baby steps for and Beyond uh
so that so with the dating thing though
I was I mean I was joking with you
earlier around like well she's nice I'd
want to go out to dinner but I mean like
you guys yeah you can date cheap I mean
it's not like you guys have to go out to
nice places and and she obviously
probably knows your goals and what's
going on and I mean there's a lot of I
mean I mean and this would be true for
married couples right or I mean anyone
dating regardless of if you're in
college or not it's just like how do you
live life while doing baby steps one
through three and you want to be able to
enjoy life to a degree uh to sustain
yourself so I mean we always talk about
you know there's there's always free
stuff going on depending on you know
your city you can look that up
um you guys I mean go on a hike I mean
like there's things that you guys can do
together that doesn't have to be crazy
expensive and instead of going to the
movie there's plenty streaming at home
for the Thousand subscription Services
we have and you can always cook a great
steak dinner at home instead of paying
10 times that at the restaurant and so
and if there's a special edition that's
my job oh that's so true which means
you're tired of cooking when you get
home best and he can cook at home and
it's restaurant quality that's true oh
yeah Gabe I would I would definitely
that's exactly part of the reason she's
dating you now this is a business yeah
yeah and you know okay too I'll say this
like this isn't forever because I know
this can seem daunting and exhausting
and you're like oh man this is just it's
a lot but this this isn't your life
forever right it's just for a season to
get an emergency fund and honestly well
done for you not only doing it at your
age but that season of life like it will
just Propel you when you graduate and
whether you continue to date her or may
I don't know if it moves on to marriage
or you go and find a career like just
setting yourself up well now it is it's
great so never regret that you're never
gonna go like man I wish I I partied
more in college that would have been so
great for me you're doing the right
things and so I want to encourage you
that you're being weird in the best ways
possible and everyone listening uh
should be encouraged by that what are
you studying
uh right on
trying machine license I'm like to teach
English at a high school level education
awesome that's great so great and what's
awesome too Gabe is like you know
obvious you know if we were talking
about Teachers Pay
um maybe a few episodes ago on my show
and I'm like and that's what's even
amazing is I'm like you can choose to go
into a career field that you know you're
not going to go make half a million
dollars right uh but you're able to make
those choices and those decisions
because you don't have payments that
you're going to have to repay so like
that's another reason doing the work on
the front end is so great because you
get to go do what you love and not be
like oh man it's gonna take me you know
eight years to get out of the student
loan debt on a teacher's salary you get
to take that teacher salary and be
blessed by it and it's great and
wonderful and you've just set yourself
up really well so that's I mean you're
doing a great job and you can still have
a life and still have a great healthy
relationship with your girlfriend and be
on baby step three this is incredible
and Rachel the data shows that students
who work 15 to 20 hours a week have a
higher GPA than those who don't yep that
makes sense to me you're going well how
is that possible well Junior has to be
real disciplined with his calendar with
his time or Gabe to do I mean Gabe's
working 40 hours a week yeah that's
insane Gabe and so well done and he's
still crushing it he's going to finish
completely dead free and so it's parents
who are going well my son can daughter
they shouldn't work they're focused on
their studies oh really are you
following them around campus all day
they're in class for a few hours a day
there's 24 hours in that day there's a
lot of other stuff happening in this
other that's right they're at the
library sure they wouldn't darken the
doors of that Library I'll tell you that
much but hey Gabe We are rooting for you
man way to go love seeing young people
just crush it and sacrifice now so they
can live their best life later awesome
more of your calls coming up AAA
825-5225 this is the Ramsay show
thank you
foreign
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is a number to call
today's question of the day is brought
to you by neighborly your hub for Home
Services when something in your home
breaks neighborly is the name to
remember and with the neighborly Done
Right promise you'll know you'll get
great service from their network of
local home service providers so go to
neighborly.com today and check them out
and today's question comes
come a b steps
group I'm saving 20 down to buy a house
in 2023 but this mortgage rates uh keep
me worried are you are we really going
to buy at six to seven percent rate next
year people's incomes are not growing as
much what are your thoughts it will take
longer to save money for a down payment
yeah and it is hard I mean if you're
seeing increases of interest rates and
you know that the price of housing has
kind of
I feel like it's definitely cooled off
studied yes has been increasing at the
same rate no no but the but the interest
rate is having people worried and so
Julie I mean just just looking at the
math we always talk about a down payment
of 10 to 20 so even if you wanted to get
into the housing market faster you could
just do save up 10 uh 20 is obviously a
wonderful goal but the 10 percent would
work but just making sure that your your
mortgage payment is no more than 25 of
your take-home pay that's the big part
of this equation and again a lot of
people fight us on that because it's
very conservative uh but here's the deal
like if half of your income is going to
a mortgage payment you're not going to
have a lot of money to go and enjoy and
to invest and to save for your kids
college and to put extra on the house to
pay it down I mean it just limits your
ability so we don't want your your house
your mortgage payment to eat up so much
of your income so that's that's the
conservative approach that we take but
honestly it it it works works
and we just took a call earlier from a
guy who could be looking at foreclosure
because they got in a house a little too
soon the point payments a little too
much and so walking to this really
peacefully with some wisdom even though
it hurts because you're looking at these
interest rates and you're going well
even if the prices stay the same a few
interest rates points higher could mean
hundreds of dollars more yeah and so
like Rachel said I would focus on that
parameter of your after-tax take-home
pay going towards the Piti principal
interest taxes insurance and that gives
you more peace it's not necessarily
about a perfect down payment number and
we're not mad at you if you put down
less than 20 percent
it's more about not having too much of
your world tied up in a mortgage payment
so I crunch some numbers using our
Ramsey mortgage calculator just to show
you what this looks like because the
numbers it's real and so let's say the
home price is 500 000 you want to put 20
down that's a hundred thousand down on a
15-year fixed well if the interest rate
was five percent your payment would be
38.47
when the interest rate goes to six
percent well now it jumps another 212
dollars to forty fifty nine if it jumps
to seven percent it jumps another two
hundred twenty dollars to 42.79 and
let's say it jumped to eight percent
it's another 227 dollars at 4506 every
month so you can see from that five to
eight percent yeah it went from 38.47 up
to 4506. yeah it's a lot from five to
eight percent so that is a real concern
but here's the good news you can always
refinance later yep and so if that if if
that interest rate your payment is
within that 25 parameter go for it you
are ready to buy a house regardless of
the interest rate and when the interest
rates go down which they inevitably Will
based on history then you can refinance
at that lower rate and a lot of people
did that people now have two three
percent interest rates
that's right which lowers their payment
so
do not fear but I think it's worth
talking about the real estate trends
that we are seeing in 2023 and uh this
is based on our blog called 2023 real
estate Trends what you need to know
we'll put the link in the show notes and
in the YouTube description for all of
you if you want to go check that out but
there's been lots of drama around buying
and selling a home in the last year
Rachel here's some Market predictions
and these just give you an idea of what
to expect again they are predictions no
one has a crystal ball so never let
these control your housing decisions
only your personal situation and your
finances should do that so for 2023 the
data is pointing toward a slightly more
stable housing market not a crash we've
been saying this for I feel like a year
now since our real estate live live
streaming though because for a while it
was the housing prices were going crazy
and there was like 42 offers on any
house that was for sale in the in a
moment and people thought oh my gosh
this is turning into a bubble and now
it's the interest rates that have people
panicking that's right and this is all
because home prices are only driven by
the law of supply and demand so when
demand is greater than Supply home
prices don't tumble so today here's the
stats there's still a shortage of homes
for sale and lots of buyer demand that
is why home prices are still going up
but they're just going up at a slower
rate so leading into 2023 the median
home price reached over 366 thousand
dollars and that's only up two point
point three percent compared to a year
ago yeah and that growth it can have
panicking in it
but listen again the housing market is
not going to crash so calm down and it
still marks a hundred and thirty
consecutive months that's over a decade
of year-over-year increases which is the
longest running streak they should win
against world record for that that's it
that's it I know so again it's not going
to crash and Freddie Mac actually
predicts overall home price growth in
2023 will drop by 0.2 percent 0.2 yes
drop that is you know small nothing to
worry about and again it's not a sign
that the market is going to crash so
again calmer prices is directly related
to supply and demand and again
historically speaking there are more
homes for sale than people wanting to
buy and so that is that's the great
thing or I'm sorry more uh more buyers
out there it's been trailing behind them
that's right that's right yep so we're
we're seeing a slight uptick in Supply
and at the start of 2023 housing
inventory was up 10.2 percent year over
year and while that's still lower than
it was before the pandemic buyers should
have more options than they did the past
few years so again looking at buyer
demand last year the average mortgage
rate increased several months in a row
which lowered demand a bit again people
weren't going out and rushing to buy
homes as the interest rates kind of
ticked up which made it affordable for
other people because you could actually
go and negotiate the price which is
great but in January mortgage rates
dropped to the lowest that they've been
since September of 2022 and Freddie Mac
forecast rates to stay pretty steady
over the rest of this year so some
buyers who held off their plans because
of rising rates last year are likely to
return to the market in 2023. so in
other words what we're seeing here is
Supply is starting to meet in the middle
with demand but we still got a ways to
go so the bottom line we won't see home
prices plummet or spike in 2023 and the
market should feel steadier I think
that's good news so never sit and wait
for home prices or mortgage rates to
drop that's like timing the stock market
we would never tell you to do that it's
impossible to time the market so if
you're in good shape financially don't
wait to pull the trigger don't wait on
the interest rates to be the perfect
interest rate it's not going to do that
you can always refinance if the rates go
down and so here's how you know if
you're in a good place you're debt free
no Consumer Debt whatsoever you have a
fully funded emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses and then you have
that down payment to where the mortgage
payment won't eat up more than 25
percent of your monthly take-home pay on
a 15-year fixed rate mortgage and that
is some of our most controversial advice
I mean every time we say 15 year they're
like these guys are 25 these guys are
crazy and I'm like you know what's crazy
foreclosing on a home at 26 because you
felt pressured to jump into it to go and
buy well and the biggest thing too I
think is yes you don't want of your you
don't want a massive mortgage payment
eating up your income because you want
to be able to do other things it's like
fund like fund retirement enjoy your
life give like do other things with your
money then just pay a mortgage payment
but also it is being debt free and
having an emergency fund in place please
have Savings in the bank yes when you go
to buy a home I mean home ownership it's
expensive things break things happen and
when you don't have money it turns out
everything into a crisis I mean it you
live on the edge and it does something
to your I mean really your anxiety level
your stress level when you don't have
money saved in the bank for any day and
that's regardless of whether you're a
homeowner or not but especially if
you're looking to buy make sure you have
an emergency fund in place before you do
that yes we can't sit here complaining
about an interest rate going up a
percent which is 200 bucks instead of
going oh it's my car payment that's
killing me it's my credit card debt
that's killing 900 car payment clean up
the debt that'll give you some margin so
if you guys want help with the stuff
we've got tons of resources for you
we've created a hub at
ramseysolutions.com home buying and we
can even connect you with expert Pros to
help you guide those decisions give you
confidence as you step into the largest
purchase of your life
tread with caution go slow follow the
Ramsay plan it works every time you work
it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by my co-host
Rachel Cruz she's also the co-host of
smart money happy hour a new episode
released yesterday about all of the
different money Traditions around the
world and I learned so much it was very
fascinating I loved it we kind of stick
to like North America America on this
show 401K the biggest the biggest North
American tradition when it comes to
money is debt that's right there's one
but so yeah so much that goes on in the
world with money it was fun go check
that out smart money happy hour wherever
you listen to podcasts and now on
YouTube if you want to see Rachel's
reactions she has some emotional
breakdowns and it's just good it's a
counter it's like a half therapy session
for me on the podcast and Sharon Ramsey
said it's her favorite podcast I know
which is my mom loves loves smart money
happy hour so make sure to check that
out number one fan all right George well
I am so excited excited because we are
we have launched our money and marriage
getaway that's going to be held here in
Nashville October 19th through the 21st
so Dr John deloney and I are hosting
this event for you and your spouse and
it is an entire weekend we've never done
this before usually money in marriage is
an evening events but we're doing an
entire weekend here in Nashville so if
you're married you know that staying
aligns is a really important thing but
it's not always easy to do and so again
we've picked an entire weekend to have
encouragement and some inspiration to
help you grow in all areas of your
marriage including your money AKA money
and marriage brilliant name I know so
you get to meet Dr John deloney and
myself and you'll have time set aside to
reflect on everything that you've
learned and how you can apply it to your
marriage right now so again this is
focus time with your spouse to work on
you and your marriage no work no kids no
errands just time for you two to connect
and here's the thing there are limited
tickets for this event and and again
it's an entire weekend so remember that
so tickets start at 699 dollars per
couple which includes so much it's a
whole package of stuff that we're going
to give you in that so talk to your
spouse and see if you can join us in
Nashville again October 19th through the
21st so go to ramseysolutions.com
events to learn more and our VIP we've
had different tiers of this and they
have all sold out like I mean like it is
crazy it has been awesome so a weekend
in Nashville with your spouse you had
something else at no work no kids no
errands that's the best pitch of all
time for everybody it's basically like
vacation except you get to learn some
stuff and you guys make it so fun this
is not your your normal marriage Retreat
where it's like just real heavy and just
like yeah no it's going to be really fun
and we're gonna pull in other speakers
and and experts too in it so it's gonna
be it's gonna be a really fun weekend
lots of Nashville flavor too that we're
planning so yeah love it all right let's
get to the phones Katie joins us in
Cedar Rapids Iowa Katie welcome to the
Ramsay show
all right thanks for taking my question
absolutely
a little backstory I've been at my
company for 31 years I guess facility
and my first seven maybe eight years
they had pension and then they started
401K probably about 25 years ago so
um I started that then but
um they kept our pension and keep
telling us how much a month we would get
from that still we just received a
letter that we need to do something with
the pension they're closing that out and
we will get a lump sum so I'm trying to
decide I have to do that something with
it before January of 24.
um I'm trying to decide what I want to
do with that or what would be the best
route to take that phone and put it in
something I really don't want to roll it
into my work 401k and Ross but
um I also don't want to get killed on
taxes or anything either
so this is this lump sum is going to be
taxable if you don't roll it over well I
don't
I don't you haven't told us the total
right now my little letter I get says
350 a month because obviously it was
only my first seven years of employment
um so you don't know the lump sum yet
I don't and I'm sure there's some
formulas I will use
um a friend of mine talked to one of our
401K people at work and they said
she's got less tenure than I do and she
said they said maybe 20 000 but I have
no idea what even to expect okay
um so let's just ballpark it for now at
25 30 000.
yes probably so tell us about your
financial situation where are you at in
the baby steps do you have any debt do
you have a mortgage
we have
um one car left and that should
hopefully be done by the end of this
year and then um just our mortgage
um which isn't a lot really um compared
to some people I guess but
um just got last child through school so
that part's done so
um that's about it and then my husband
and I are both 53. okay what do you guys
have in your nest egg currently combined
all retirement accounts combined yep uh
probably a little over six hundred
thousand
all right and how much money do you guys
have in the bank just kind of liquid
cash
uh ten thousand
okay what's left on the car loan
um I think 18.
all right and lastly what is your
household income
um well last year it was definitely
higher I'm a nurse in they threw a lot
of money out of the last year so average
our household income is probably about
170. awesome
cool yeah that's great that's great
Katie yeah well I would figure out
obviously the lump sum and then talk to
them yeah about about the tax situation
because if you're able just to roll it
into a Roth and a 401k and kind of keep
it in that Rhythm I'm not mad at that
honestly I mean I think that that's that
could be a great option especially if
there's if there's tax implications that
are going to happen if not and you can
just cash out the 30 grand there's a lot
that you could do with that right now
Katie I mean you could be paying off
this car with that you guys could be
having a larger emergency funds that you
can use that so
um yeah depending on the tax situation
if you are penalized by taking that lump
sum at your age I would roll it over to
yeah to avoid taxes my guess is it's
like a traditional not raw so you'd
probably want to move it to a
traditional IRA direct rollover so
privately because I have
um I moved to um my 401k is Roth and
401K depends I split it up
um so I could get the match and
everything for the 401K but
um I didn't know if I needed to do that
privately like a private IRA
well you wouldn't do it through your
employer an IRA is outside of your
employer individual retirement accounts
is your is your 401k a Roth 401k and you
have a Roth IRA is that correct no it is
it is a you can divert you can put your
money in straight 401k or Roth or both
so you have a mix of traditional and
Roth in there I
because the employer match by default is
going to go into the traditional side
currently it is it is correct yeah okay
so I would get do some homework find out
what that lump sum is going to be find
out what the tax implications are your
best bet is going to be to roll it over
into a retirement account without any
penalties and at this point I think you
guys need that for it to grow for the
next 10 years to add to your nest egg
right so I and if there are no tax
implications you want to wipe out your
debt and add to the emergency fund
that's a great goal too but you still
need to think about how can we get to a
million dollar nest egg in the next 10
years
yeah yeah and that's what my thing was
the whole taxes that's what I don't know
anything about it and they we just got
this letter this week so I'm trying to
like start looking at it so yeah well I
would meet with a smart investor Pro and
even if you have you know someone that
helps you with your taxes if you have a
CPA you know sitting down because you
have you have what six months nine
months
um to figure it out by January so I
would go ahead and start that because
regardless of what the amount is you're
going to want to know exactly what it
entails from a penalties and tax
perspective and that's going to help you
make your decision
yes I did um go online and type in my
address for the smartvester pro and I'm
not kidding it was 20 seconds after I
hit submit I got a phone call from
somebody good yeah trained them well we
tell them hey we want you to get in
touch because when you want that help we
want you to get the help as soon as
possible now wait three days to hear
from someone that was like I was like
what in the heck and it was somebody
calling me already so that's awesome um
we'd love to hear that they've all
contacted me through phone and email
since so good yeah we'll sit down and
meet with them I mean honestly Katie and
they're going to be able to help you too
with your whole picture of just you know
tax strategy and estate yeah going
forward
um and especially with your age and
stuff sitting down with someone I think
is really really key it gives you
confidence instead of hoping and wishing
for the next 10 years you go oh we know
exactly where we're headed yeah exactly
well thank you so great thanks Katie
thanks great conversation well I love
hearing that about smart investor Pros
because they really are it's incredible
Winston and I sat down with ours in
January and I'm sitting with him and
granted we do this every day which I
want my everyday but he I mean he's just
like throwing data at me and all this
and it wasn't intimidating but I'm like
you do you breathe this in and out all
day every day and you love it so these
people want to help you guys so make
sure to check it out love it hey that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
books my thanks to my co-host Rachel
Cruz all the folks in the booth keeping
the show afloat and you America we
appreciate you listening we're going to
be back real soon
foreign
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsay
show where we help people build wealth
do work they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell Ramsay
personality Join This Hour by Rachel
Cruz and we are taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five Josh joins us up next
in Johnson City Tennessee Josh welcome
to the Ramsey show how you doing
doing good hey thanks uh you guys for
helping everybody out today I appreciate
it absolutely what's going on with you
so I'll try to keep it brief I feel like
you guys will probably answered this
close to 100 times in the past couple
months
um my wife and I are first-time home
buyers we're not quite in the market yet
um with our income and our situation you
know we've done the baby steps we're
2-3b we're saving money every month and
putting them into actually some mutual
funds to try and gain some interest on
that stuff
um but in this market it just it feels
almost impossible I mean there's houses
in my area for
you know three bedroom two bathroom
uh 1700 square feet for 325 000 and you
know as a family of four with two jobs
and a business uh it's um it's just not
it's not feasible so like what kind of
advice do you have for individuals and
couples and families in these kinds of
situations
so how much money do you have saved
so we've got you know towards the house
right now we only have three but we're
putting 500 a month in some mutual funds
okay Josh I I hesitate where you're
putting your money I understand you want
it to grow but it's so volatile and last
year I mean it's doing better now the
market but I mean if you had that money
and it last year you would have lost a
lot of that
um and so we usually say with investing
it takes about five years kind of for
the ride the up and down to actually see
some level of growth where it feels like
steady and you know consistent
um and right now money markets and high
yield savings accounts I mean your the
percentages you can get four percent of
these high-yield savings right now yeah
so it's a guaranteed versus the market
yeah so again if you guys are going to
be buying a home in the next two three
four years I honestly would hesitate
putting them in mutual funds I
understand what you're what you're
saying
um to get some kind of growth but I it's
still a little too volatile and too
short of a timeline to do that
even even if it was in one of those high
yield savings you know within five years
that's you know I mean we'll be talking
35 40 000 and that's that's ten percent
on something I'd still be house broke
you know
well the interest is not going to be the
the winning Factor here it's your
savings rate and so the real question is
why can't we save more than five hundred
dollars towards the down payment every
month if we have no payments in the
world
yeah so that's what I would focus on how
much you guys bringing home a month
bringing home
um
typically about
5 000 close to maybe a little under
and you said that's between two jobs and
a business
yeah yeah my business just started
kicking off last year I'm hoping to
getting some this year but it's not
looking like that as of right now okay
and are you doing the two jobs is your
wife working outside the home
I'm doing my wife and I both have
full-time jobs and I have a side
businesses right now okay so the other
part of this equation is can we get one
of those incomes up or both incomes up
uh by switching jobs
gotcha
okay yeah and I hear you Josh I know I
know it's defeating and you know we're
we see the numbers we're in Nashville so
like we know but but here's what's so
hard and I feel like we have this
conversation a lot with people in
California because I'm in California and
so what do I do but math is math and
that's what's difficult you know when we
sit in our seats that we know that
there's a person on the other side right
Josh like you and your family and it's
like yeah you guys want to be homeowners
you want to be able to go and
um and own a home which we want you to
do that too I think homeownership is a
really important part of your entire
financial plan but we don't want it to
wreck you and so what what sucks right
now is that yeah what you could have
done four years ago with buying a house
it looks different today but the math
doesn't change and so we don't we don't
adjust our formula and the way we go
about buying
um you know the the wise way of buying a
home that really doesn't shift you know
depending on how the market is doing it
is it's there and consistent regardless
because again we go back to that math we
don't want you to put nothing down get a
terrible mortgage you know in it being
half of your income I mean all of that
would create more stress that dream of
owning a home ends up becoming a burden
and so again I know it's frustrating and
it's going to take time
um and and you guys again whether it's
your incomes go up or your business
takes off or even the market adjusts a
little bit you know I mean all of this
can be part of the equation but you do
want to stay on that path
um of looking to save up again we always
say 10 at the minimum for a down payment
uh to be there and and you may not get
as much house as you would of years ago
and again that's so frustrating I know
it's so frustrating uh but that's that's
where we are right now we but we just
don't once you know all the listeners
including you Josh to go and do
something to wreck your financial
situation just just to have a house if
that makes sense
yeah no totally I I definitely agree
with that I mean that's that's why I was
just reaching out to those who might
know a little bit more than me yeah and
so what you were saying in like so give
give us some of the things that you guys
are finding when you when you look at
you know if you're looking up on Zillow
or whatever maybe what are the houses
going for did you say around your area
um something that would feasibly
accommodate what we need and what we not
even what we want really what we need is
320 to 370 000. okay yep yeah we just
did an article about the
um the housing market I think the median
house 360. it's 366. so that um in
America today yeah so what this means is
it's more patience and more income
because we can't control the market so
if I'm you're in your shoes I'm taking
the money out of those mutual funds I'm
going to put them into a high-yield
savings account be aware of the tax
implications based on the gains as you
do that but that's going to give you a
more guaranteed return versus what if
the market goes down 20 and now you're
extra defeated because you're pouring
money into this thing and you the
balance is lower than when you started
so that's my big fear on that side on
the other side the question remains what
is in your control is making more money
how do we turn that 500 bucks into a
thousand bucks into two thousand bucks
think about how that changes the numbers
two thousand dollars over the course of
a year that's 25 Grand a year three
years from now that's 75 grand we have
for a down payment yeah because being
able to do that if you're a thousand
dollars a month saving towards a house
payment I mean within two two and a half
years you guys would have a down payment
to be able to go forward with buying a
house so again it's it's the patient's
part as well so it's it's finding that
extra income where you can
um and again making it an aggressive
goal so even lifestyle wise say saying
okay you know are there are there things
we can cut here there I mean even 50 100
bucks per month you know helps that
timeline decrease if that's really a
goal you guys want to do here in the
next three years so it is possible but
it's I mean it's patience but but also
and let me say this Josh time does fly
let me say that I know three years is
like that sounds so exhausting but three
years ago it was 2020 it was you know
March of 2020 was three years ago and
granted that was the weirdest three
years of any of our lives but but that's
what I'm saying is like a lot time goes
quickly so even though it seems long and
daunting stick with it and you're going
to be so glad that you did absolutely
thanks for the call man this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
C of chm could be right for your family
learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
I'm George Campbell joined by Rachel
Cruz this hour this is the Ramsay show
you can give us a call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money well Rachel I like to get
riled up by videos on social media and
one favorite I stumbled upon one that
really got my blood boiling and I wanted
to get your take on it you have not seen
this I feel like a magician being like
you have never seen it I love the live
reactions I want to play it and uh a
little spark a little conversation about
it so let's roll that beautiful Bean
footage
why is your car payment thirteen hundred
dollars because first of all this
vehicle was sixty two thousand dollars I
did it for 60 months instead of 72 and I
went zero down just didn't want to put
any money down because it's just it
doesn't make any sense to me you put how
much money do you save if you put more
money down so basically every thousand
dollars that you put down is about
twenty dollars so it would take five
grand for me to lower my monthly payment
by a hundred dollars so in thirteen
hundred versus twelve hundred yeah the
same thing you know take you what is
that 60 months to get your money back or
50 months oh yeah
it'd take way too long
wow
Rachel some people's cornbread just
ain't down in the middle you know they
just didn't didn't fully bake in the
oven so this is let me recap what this
guy just said
he bought a vehicle that was sixty two
thousand dollars MSRP
with zero down 1300 bucks a month for 60
months which if you're doing the math at
home is seventy eight thousand dollars
for a vehicle that was worth sixty two
thousand dollars before he drove it off
the lot in that it's yeah it's
appreciated already and so his logic
though has nothing to do with the
interest paid he's going why would I put
more down it's only going to lower the
payment by a hundred bucks what's the
difference between twelve hundred and
thirteen hundred
and this is why we're broke it's not in
we can't keep blaming inflation and eggs
at some point we have to look in the
mirror and go stop being an idiot stop
buying 62 000 cars and paying 78 000 for
them while making fifty thousand and
then going oh I wish Biden would really
fix it and the taxes and the Egg prices
are out of control Rachel I'm going full
King of the Hill at this point oh I love
it George well for me car payment car
loans car payments it's like it's it's
the it's my worst type of debt if we had
a rate debt for me it's the most
annoying you know student loans you get
a degree it's stupid that's probably
second like I mean like sure uh credit
cards people are like we'll pay it off
every whatever so if we rate the debt
car loans for me it's the it's the
dumbest and it's the one you can justify
the most but but mathematically speaking
when you just look at your finances it
is it's the it's the dumbest thing that
you can do with your money it really is
because you're borrowing money paying
interest on something that's going down
in value it's not an asset and it's for
what
I'm being serious like I'm like this is
unbelievable like it's it's one thing
when we talk to people and they're in
credit card debt because they're behind
on their bills and they're trying to let
you know what I mean like in your and
you're kind of talking through this
needs versus wants and uh you know we
get those calls you know all the time
but I'm like but a car payment it's it's
literally two for sixty two thousand
dollars to look a certain way and feel a
certain way it's an ego thing the book
the psychology of money have you read it
oh no Delaney told me so good I've heard
great things but I loved what he said in
there he said really the re the reason
people don't save like it it's it's your
ego
and so if this guy's ego was out of the
way and drove a great Honda Civic now
and didn't have that car payment
he would be able to save
that what thirteen hundred dollars a
month but instead and invest it but it's
going into a not an asset it's again
because it goes down in value it's not
even like two thousand dollar car is now
worth fifty and then 40. I mean it's
just and again it's a for a car to get
to point A to point B and I'm not mad at
cars we like cars sure uh so it's not
that but it's it's the way we our
mindsets around it and financially how
it plays out it just becomes such a huge
burden on on families and
uh it's it's not wise well shopping for
a guy come on dude like we have such a
culture of debt that we're so obsessed
with debt that the logic doesn't go to
hey how much am I paying an interest
instead it goes well my payments
actually you know it's 100 bucks more
but what's the point of putting more
money down just save 100 bucks on my
payment right we're still thinking in
such a stupid lens of what's the payment
can I afford the payment you're not even
looking at the entire mathematical
equation and for getting interest in all
of it yeah well here's where that
short-term thinking leads us Rachel okay
the CBS News article millions of
Americans nearing retirement age with no
savings so here's a real sad story of a
woman who's juggling two jobs she's 66
years old sometimes working up to 11
hours a day hoping wishing to be retired
playing piano enjoying her life but she
has no savings or 401K not even enough
to cover an emergency she sold her home
and bought a smaller one with two other
women
at 66 yeah yeah this is really sad and
here's the stats the U.S Census Bureau
data shows that 50 of women and 47 of
men between 55 and 66 years old have no
retirement savings half
zilch that's pretty wild that if you
were to quiz me if we did a pop quiz I
wouldn't think it was that high I didn't
think it was that high oh
and she said I have a live for now
philosophy I guess
you think
I mean it's shocking to me that people
wake up at 66 and go I should probably
do something about that retirement thing
huh instead of using time while we have
it on this our precious time on earth
right right to retire with dignity and
have a great life and so this is really
really sad according to AARP
um you know experts say it's not too
late to make a plan which means we're
continuing to work we're lowering cost
of living saving when you can delaying
Social Security benefits until 70 to get
the largest check possible
the problem is people can't delay those
Social Security checks because they need
them now yeah they have because they're
so broke
and so this is just a I think the
situation is only going to get worse
if America doesn't wake up
oh my gosh yeah so it's just and again
regardless of what age you are we are in
the the business of hope to be like you
can do something different about your
situation again regardless of your age
but when you have time on your side so
young people out there were talking to
it is it's so important to look at the
future and the problem is George like we
want everything right now we want our
life to feel good we want to we want to
do what we want and saying no to what we
want in the moment is not it's not
popular and people you know it's so easy
just to fall into that instant
gratification and again we're not saying
that you can't have a life and you can't
enjoy your life and enjoy your money but
it has to be in a level of a proper
order and for it to make sense and the
problem is is that people there's not a
plan there's not a level of
intentionality and it's just living
paycheck to paycheck and you just go
through your life and then you wake up
at 66 and you're thinking oh my gosh I
have nothing to say so we just don't
want that for you and the truth is it's
not that hard to be a millionaire you
just need to put a little bit away
consistently over a long period of time
yep so the math isn't that hard it's the
emotion it's the behavior it's the
habits and so I'm plugging in this guy's
1300 car payment into our investment
calculator on 30 years old if you
started with zero dollars and you
invested that thirteen hundred dollar
car payment into the stock market into a
good index fund a mutual fund at 65 you
would have 3.8 million dollars is that
if you invested every month if you
invest 1300 bucks every month which this
guy people like this will always have a
car yeah yeah for sure 100 of a big car
payment and you'd have close to four
million dollars and you have close to
four million yep instead he could be
like this poor woman and that's it for
me where I'm like you're choosing to to
drive a car or have four million dollars
like that's that's it but he's out here
peddling his wealth hacks the ego
yes like it's I mean seriously that's
that's what happens any bro bragging
about his 62 000 car was zero down and
here's what's funny too I'll quote the
same book because he talked about how he
was a the author was a valet in DC
and he said he would park I mean insane
cars like you know Lamborghinis I mean
just like Porsche all the all the
amazing cars and he said what's funny
about being a valet and for majority of
people out there when you see an awesome
car
you look at the car and you think that's
a cool car could I ever drive that car
you start imagining yourself in that car
what do I need to do to drive that car
you're not looking at the actual driver
and looking at the looking at the the
man or the woman and thinking oh I
wonder what with that guy oh and you
start you know wondering about the
driver no you're looking at the car so
it's even like we kind of puff up
ourselves of like oh I'm gonna drive a
cool car because people are going to
think I'm successful they're really not
even looking at you they're looking at
the car so like and the crazy part is
I've got a friend who's got a really
expensive car hundreds of thousands of
dollars afraid to drive it wouldn't you
be oh man imagine driving your house
around worrying you're gonna get a
scratch on the thing you're parking 19
miles away so that no someone doesn't
see your door I know we weren't mentally
like this Mo Money Mo Problems amen
and I'd rather have more money in the
bank than in stuff going down in value
let's make good choices America this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trustee
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I'm George Campbell she's Rachel Cruz
this is the Ramsay show the number to
call is triple eight eight two five five
two two five well with debt payments and
inflation stealing more and more of your
paycheck we know a lot of you out there
feel like you're drowning and you're
scared to death that you won't have
enough to take care of your family but
you shouldn't have to live with that
kind of stress and if you want things to
change you've got to have your I've had
at moment you've got to try some new
things with your money and that means
it's time time to try Financial Peace
University this is our Flagship money
course nine lessons that will teach you
how to beat debt and build wealth it's
everything you wish you learned about
how to handle money growing up
and nearly 10 million people have taken
Financial Peace University and they'll
be the first to tell you they don't
worry about money like they used to
they're in control now and you can be
too but you've got to decide that you're
done stressing about money and take
control you can start Financial Peace
University right now at
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com FPU
Richard joins us up next in Richmond
Virginia Richard welcome to the show
oh sorry let me get on the right line
here there we go how you doing
hi George hi
Rick great how can we help today yes my
question has to do with the rule of 55
um I turned 55 this year and I was
wondering how I can access my 401K money
without paying a penalty I currently
have an advisor and his path was to was
my provider I had to take a lump sum I
can't take distributions from it
so he suggested taking the lump sum out
putting a portion of it into an IRA
which I wouldn't touch to 59 and a half
and then the other portion would go into
a mutual fund where that's where I would
get my money until 59 and a half so I
was wondering if I did that will I incur
any penalties because I told them I
don't want a penalty he said no there
will be no penalty if you do it this way
my other question is if that is willing
and current penalty incur a penalty with
that what I then have to do what's
called a 72t without incurring a penalty
have you talked to a CPA about this as
far as the tax implications
no I have not okay it might be a good
step but we can walk you through I what
I assume your advisor is talking about
is taking part of the lump sum and
creating a bridge account so that from
55 to 59 and a half that is your money
to live off of
and then we can access the rest of that
through the IRA without penalty
right that yeah that's his suggestion
how much do you have make sure
uh in my 401k I currently have about 1.1
million awesome and is your plan to like
officially retire
uh
medical insurance because my employer
doesn't offer retiring medical insurance
so I would work part-time to help pay
for that okay and are you 55 currently
this year awesome okay well I'm I'm
reading about it I know about the rule
of 55 I'm looking into the details of it
uh it's saying withdrawals must be made
in the year that the employee turns 55
and leaves their employer either to
retire early or for any other reason of
course it applies to workplace plans
only and retirement plan distributions
taking this rule would still be subject
to ordinary income tax
so that tells me there's going to be
some tax implications here
okay
so I would factor that into your plan
okay are these traditional is this all
traditional money yes okay
because of course if it was Roth you
wouldn't have to pay taxes on this but
because it's traditional it'd be just
like your normal 401K 59 and a half and
you're withdrawing from that
so the question is do you need this
money to get by for the next four years
do you have any other savings any other
retirement accounts
about 1.5 million saved okay so the you
said you had 1.1 in this retirement
account you have another 400 000
elsewhere yes okay and where is that
uh that's in part of it is in a
inherited IRA uh that I got from my uh
father when he passed away and the
others is my own mutual funds that I've
been putting money into I'm wondering
can we tap those and use those to get by
for the next four and a half years
is your main motivation Richard because
you want to retire
uh yes
I retired without penalty that that's my
key I said I don't want any penalty and
he assured me there is no penalty I just
want to make sure yeah it won't be a
penalty but the taxes but you'll you'd
still be paying the taxes at 59 and a
half I mean it's because it's a
traditional yeah and either way you're
going to pay taxes yeah on the growth so
whether it's at 55 or 59 and a half
um that will be there so yeah I would
look to see okay how much taxes will be
paid
um on the growth I just pay taxes on
what I'm taking out of the mutual fund
or would I pay taxes on the IRA and the
mutual fund now the IRA is at a
traditional IRA yes
yeah I don't know that you can you
access that at 55
oh
and up and touch the 59 and a half yeah
you'll probably be able to roll that
over yeah and avoid taxes with that if
you if you roll it over to a traditional
IRA but when you take it out and open up
a mutual fund that amount of money
probably will be taxable
right which is what he told me that he
told me that is this advisor one of our
smart master Pros or is this outside of
that
I'm just curious if you contacted one of
our smartvestor pros and get a second
opinion on your situation and see what
they would recommend
okay but as far as you know that there
wouldn't be any federal no IRS penalty
doing this route
as long as you're doing the rule of 55
and only tapping into the workplace plan
it would just be your normal taxes but
no penalties
okay and what about a 72 T I'm not sure
about the 72 t uh as far as your
situation goes what is your
understanding of that
um
I own that you have to take a set amount
out every year for at least five years
um you know uh based on your uh age and
how much you have saved and that you
have to you know do it for at least five
years if not then you'll be penalized if
you were to stop or wanted more money or
you know what have you okay with the
bridge account I'm still gonna try to
use the funds you have through these
mutual funds and the inherited IRA and
try to use that as your Bridge account
and see if we can leave that other money
there until we need it
okay but I would get that second opinion
from the smartvester pro yeah because
you're I mean this is you know we're
talking about a lot of zeros on the end
of this well that yeah and and it's a
big shift right if you're wanting to
retire I mean this is a big life change
that's happening and you're shifting
your entire Nest Egg
um so I probably yeah I'm with George I
would get a second opinion just to
double check a couple of things and
making sure that there's not another
route because the other you know if you
sit down with I mean I don't know what
they'll say but a summer investor Pro
they may look at it and be like well no
actually if you leave it in here that's
actually smarter because you can use
this other money here and you know it's
like a big puzzle piece is what ends up
happening yeah
um or if it's consistent advice then
then you know that's the right route but
since it's such a big decision uh
especially when it comes to your
retirements and that you're actively
going to be retiring uh you want to make
sure that yeah you're doing this exactly
right and we've got to have a full
picture of your financial situation
which is you know hard to do in a five
minute radio call so I don't want you to
go well Rachel told me to on a five
minute call and all this sudden you know
your life shifts drastically so I'd walk
very carefully through this big decision
and get a few opinions before you make
it but also it's exciting Richard I mean
this is you've done a great job and
you're you're the opposite of what we
were talking about another segment of
retiring broke yeah I mean you have it
and yeah and there's a way to be smart
and strategic about these funds that's
going to help you more and more in the
future so yeah you don't want to do
something
Dom and pay more and penalties of
something that you know is unnecessary
so well done for you and and
congratulations yeah I'm retiring too
but it's a fun conversation for those
that do want to retire quote unquote
early before 59 and a half because there
is a great mix of there's tax deferred
like you're traditional there's tax-free
like your Roth and there's taxable
through your brokerage account and so
through that mix you can create a really
cool strategy to go oh I can retire at
55 and use this bridge account with this
brokerage money without touching
retirement because most people can't
they don't have the money at 55 to be
able to do it yes uh for a majority of
people so the fact that's yeah you're
able to but you're right there's so many
there's so many parts of the equation
that you want to look at and you just
want to be wise with it because
uh it's amazing in that world again why
we love smart faster Pros is they
usually can find some strategy to say oh
yeah here's how you can save here you
know if you take the growth out here and
live on that I mean it's it's a whole
strategic play tax brackets and taxable
income and so it's a very nuanced
discussion but it's one worth having
with a trained professional like these
Marvel Pro so way to go with your whole
financial plan Richmond proud of you man
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz this hour
if you're a new listener to the show
first of all welcome we're glad you're
here but if you're looking for a deeper
dive on what we're all about the Ramsay
baby steps the money plan you can go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button and we'll help you figure
out the best next step for your
financial Journey based on exactly where
you are today again that's
ramseysolutions.com us get started
button that's all you need to click Ray
joins us up next right here in Nashville
Tennessee Ray welcome to the show
hey how are you we're doing great how
can we help
uh yes I have a question I'll kind of
make it fast um so I have a collection
and um I called the company to see if we
can settle on it and they said no and
the only show I'm having is because they
upcharged it about 500 bucks of what I
originally owed
up charges in penalties and fees
I'm guessing they just sent me a letter
and I owe them I think 1379 with the
original
um what I owed before that was
849. what kind of debt is this
uh this is just from a apartment complex
of about some carpet
okay some damage when you left yeah
basically for a pet even though I paid
the pet deposit but they said something
about or they still had the change of
what they charged me for it
so can you ask for an itemized bill
that shows all the charges
with uh with the collections or the
apartment both because collections
legally they have to give you an
itemized bill of exactly what they're
actually charging you for
okay now I do have a I do remember
seeing um but basically they were saying
that you know they had to do the carpet
and they charged me for that then they
charged me for the labor and then they
charged me uh for some type of steal
kill it because I guess I got a puppy so
you know potty training and whatnot so
I'm guessing um they said the urine you
know kind of lingers you know what I
mean that smell so they had to like coat
something off across the whole apartment
with that so that's why they said it was
8 49. did you check your lease agreement
do you still have a copy of that
um no I do not
not emailed nowhere
um maybe in my emails I possibly could I
mean this has probably been about two
three years ago so I don't think I would
have it in paper but I could definitely
check my email okay I'm just wondering
if you can go back through there and
look through the fine print even going
to the apartment complex and saying hey
do you guys have my old lease agreement
on file and looking through that and
just having a discussion with them
now it's already in collections so
they're not gonna be able to do anything
about it they've already sold that debt
to collections but if you can at least
get the lease agreement from them you'll
at least have a little more ammo when it
comes to you know what your legal rights
are here
okay
but if if you can't negotiate with them
you're gonna have to pay it but I would
first at least get an itemized Bill to
understand what you're paying yeah
because you want to be able to look at
look at what the collections with the
fees and all that to be able to because
that that will give you ammo as well
being somewhat knowledgeable of what
this is like hey well let's just take
off this this and this off the line Adam
and reduce it here you know as you kind
of start the negotiation versus just hey
will you just give me a lower payment uh
so as much information as you can have
Ray it's really going to help you but
yeah see what the pet policy is
um did they refund you your safety to
put like when you um
safety deposit
no ma'am
so that feels like you shouldn't have
been charged extra on top of that if you
already they kept your deposit so again
that lease agreement is going to tell
you everything you need to know because
that's what they are legally Bound by
it's what you're legally Bound by and it
may not be worth fighting I'm not saying
you should go to small claims court over
this do you have the money to pay it
yes I do okay
so at the end of the day yeah if it if
nothing budges I would just pay it and
we call it stupid tax around here it's
stuff that you're like Dad come in
at this point is the dog still with you
yep yep she's still with me I think the
dog needs to Pony up and pay for this
yeah I wish you'd get a job but it
doesn't work like that what what kept
you from paying it the last three years
did you forget about it and then you got
a letter and realized that you owed it
um well I actually bought a house
um probably about an hour away from
Nashville
um a couple months go by and I just get
a random letter and you know I was just
dealing with all you know you know
fixing up the house and stuff so money
was a little tight so I kind of just
blew it off you know what I mean
gotcha yeah so look at the lease
agreement like George said is going to
help but there may be a factor in their
array that yeah if it's enough damage
you may be the one liable for it and
then again seeing the itemize of what
the collections what they added on to it
um because they may have had some type
of
small interest on it you know as the
months go by or 500 feels like a big
swing there so I think if you have the
proof that it was 8.49 and you have that
itemized and you say to collections hey
I'm not paying this until I see an
itemized bill because what I'm seeing is
8.49 which I'm happy to pay but I'm not
going to pay this extra 500 without
knowing what it is
okay okay have you tried that yeah have
you tried the thing of um kind of the
tactic of like hey I have 849 right now
you just take it
yeah yeah I tried that I tried to
negotiate you know I was like you know
can we just come to a price agreement I
could pay it today and she's like okay
let me take a look um and she said no
there's no option for that right now
I would call back I mean honestly right
those most most collection agencies just
just think of Office Space the movie
where they're just in a bunch of
cubicles soulless and they they don't
want to do this job and that lady you
talked to honestly probably isn't going
to be there in 90 days even I mean like
the turnover rate all of it so I would
almost just keep trying get the itemized
Bill ask for the supervisor yeah keep
calling and asking because you could
call tomorrow and they could give you a
different answer that's true depends on
who you get so good luck man this is a I
know it's a tough situation the great
thing is too right if you had to pay it
you have the money so that's that's the
upside on all of this absolutely all
right let's move on to Chelsea in Boise
Chelsea welcome to the Ramsay show how
you doing hey George and Rachel how are
you guys we are doing great now that
we're talking to a bundle of sunshine
I love it
I desperately need some Financial Guru
advice
well we are we are not gurus but we'll
try we can help we will do our best
we'll do our friends who are happy to
Google it then I'm a mega fan so it's I
need it I'm in a bit of a pickle
so I'm kind of stuck I'm in baby step
two currently right now and I find
myself in need of replacing a
transmission which is fine or buying a
new car and I don't know what to do when
I'm stuck okay how much how much will
the transition transmission be
okay so right now we're looking at three
thousand supposing that's all that's
wrong with it if it's not like you know
an engine rebuild or anything like that
I think how much is the car worth
the cards only worth about a thousand to
fifteen hundred it's a 2003 Ford
Explorer with about 212 000 miles on it
and you check the Kelly Blue Book value
on this for Private Sales yeah and it's
about a thousand bucks yeah about 15 if
we were lucky oof yeah I would say I
would say the three grand honestly uh
I'd probably sell it for a thousand sell
it for a thousand and take three four
thousand yeah I get a four thousand
dollars
so the caveat is we have about according
to the every dollar app or the baby
steps app that we use yeah which is
fantastic by the way
um it's about we have about 22 uh
thousand dollars in debt so that's kind
of where I'm caught up we have about
nine thousand dollars but we're using
the envelope system
um and so it's like wrapped up in like
different subcategories so if we had a
liquid diet like liquidate everything we
could and we would have about nine in
cash what would you be liquidating
like different categories of the
envelope system so it's like wrapped up
in like I like different sinking funds
yeah okay yeah yeah well I mean in this
case Chelsea we always say you know this
is part of your four walls so having a
car that runs is is an essential we we
would consider that a need so for the
time being what I would do since you
guys are in baby step two you know it's
yeah it's a you know you could sell it
for a thousand bucks
and then maybe take two thousand and go
get another three thousand you know
three thousand dollar car to get you
through some of the baby steps so that
you're not depleting oh I don't want you
you know depleting all of your savings
but also this nine grand could start
going to this twenty two thousand
dollars in debt as well
so we do have another car my husband
works four jobs so he has
um you know he's a firefighter an EMT he
does it he does it a lesson
so we have a Ford Explorer that's a
little bit newer not by much but we do
have two cars
um so we could sell one and just go down
to one car I like this plan Chelsea you
could do that too for a bit tell me
about our family yep until you save up
and you get a clunker that gets you
around for now remember it's all
temporary we're gonna be out of this
pickle real soon appreciate the call
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books
camel you like what you heard in this
episode and want to know more about
getting started on the Ramsay baby steps
go to ramsaysolutions.com and click on
the get started button we'll help you
figure out the best next step for you
based on your specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
thank you
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work they love and create
amazing relationships I'm Ramsey
personality George Campbell join this
hour by the Rachel Cruz that's right the
official Rachel Cruz is here with us
today taking your calls about life and
money at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Anthony kicks us off
this hour in Philly Anthony welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi George and Rachel thank you so much
for taking my call today we're happy to
take it what's going on with you
so as an 18 year old how can I start
Building Wealth early to ensure that
I'll be able to save for a house not too
late in my life that's a fantastic
question can I just say the fact that
you are thinking about this calling in
with this question tells me that you are
going to build wealth so I want to
encourage you with that that it's going
to happen
because of your mindset which is the
most important part so I love the
question let's get into your your
financial picture so you're 18 are you
going to college are you going to work
um I'm going to college uh starting in
September I'm going to a community
college love it and I I do work I am a
utility worker at a retirement community
cool what do you make there
I make 14.70 an hour
and do you have any debt
um no not yet but I will probably have
to take out some student loans no
eventually Anthony we were we had a good
thing going you said not yet
yeah how do we avoid this how much is
the Community College
um each year it's about 5500 okay
so per semester yeah you're yeah
okay and how much how many hours do you
work
oh I work during school I'm I'm still in
high school right now during school I
work about 30 hours a week oh wow
awesome and is this a two-year Community
College
yes so we're talking 11 grand for the
two years
yes okay so that to me now becomes our
goal how do we come up with 11 Grand
over the two years to cash flow this so
we can get out of this thing completely
debt free
mm-hmm well I do have some problems with
saving and spending but I am trying I so
I do try and then think problems pop up
and what do you mean by problems
like stuff with my car and some and I
have a I do like spending money and I
really try to stop that especially you
know my friends they ask to go out and
it's really hard to refuse sometimes
are y'all yeah we're just to be a little
specific like where are you guys going
like does it cost a lot of money what
you guys are doing as seniors in high
school
um we you know we go out to eat and
stuff like that and we go to movies and
stuff you know things that we like to do
we have fun but sometimes it does wind
up costing a little more than I'd expect
especially with uh get driving and gas
and are you on the hook for all of that
um
personally or your parents helping you
at all where are you at with that
well I usually don't like asking my
parents for anything especially if it's
something not important I really don't
like asking anybody for money unless
it's something absolutely like I need it
okay so if you don't like asking have
you guys had a conversation about
college at all with your parents oh yes
okay and it's and you're on the hook for
it all
um they're gonna help me out perfect we
can't they can't afford to pay for the
whole thing so sure how much are they
going to pay
um approximately like three thousand
four thousand dollars for the entire
thing
yeah okay so that's I mean that's right
seven or eight yep so that's gonna yeah
and I'm and I'm looking at this per
semester Anthony because I think our big
so your number one goal is to go to
college debt free okay so a couple
things you have going for you that's
really great is you're working you have
a job so your work ethic is there uh
you're going to a community college
which is even less expensive than a
state score I'm for sure out of state so
your school choice is really really
great and so if your parents you know if
you you know maybe they say yeah four
thousand dollars
um which would be two thousand dollars a
year
that you could use that money uh and a
thousand dollars a semester which means
you only have to you only have to figure
out really 15 1700 a semester to get
through it debt free yeah because for a
lot of this the tuition is going to be
due per semester you can even get put on
a payment plan a cash flow payment plan
with a community college so all you need
to come up with Anthony if if
everything's as I'm seeing is correct
yeah you're you're only having to to
come up with like 1700 bucks per
semester and you can do that working I
mean I guess some of the numbers you
just told me 14.70 an hour 30 hours a
week that's 1764 a month before taxes
right
that's 21 Grand you're making before
taxes and that's Anthony working you
know with a high school schedule so once
you start Community College you may have
classes just from like nine to one p.m
and then pick up another job so yeah
yeah I would not Anthony I would not
take out student loans I would really
make it a goal make it a challenge for
you to say I'm not an option yeah it's
not an option so what do I have to do
how do I figure this out to pay for it
and honestly the numbers here are so
reasonable and doable Anthony and you're
doing it a really smart way like hear us
say that because college today we are
all for higher education but people have
lost their freaking Minds when it comes
to college and it's insane what people
are paying for to get a degree that may
not even be marketable out in the world
I mean it's just it's a mess and so what
you're doing is is really wise and
you're getting a two-year degree and
that's really great at a community
college and so
um all of that is so great so I would I
would really put my efforts and instead
of thinking about a house long term
think about Hey how how can I get
through these next two years each
semester how do I have four semesters I
need a cash flow and how do I do that
and it's and it may be possible and I
mean no it is possible
um because yeah these numbers are are so
doable I'm very encouraged so here's the
deal you asked us how can I build well
thoroughly and the truth is I'm not
going to tell you to invest in the next
two years the best way to build wealth
is to graduate completely debt free so
that when you start a career a full-time
job you get every single one of those
dollars you keep them instead of sending
it to lenders every month and that
allows you to have the margin to begin
investing and to put 15 in your 401k and
you're gonna have an emergency fund by
then of three to six months of expenses
so you never need to turn to debt which
is only going to delay your wealth
building Journey
so I wouldn't invest until you you have
that full-time job then you can begin
investing at 15 as long as you're debt
free with the emergency fund and that's
going to be your best course to build
wealth if you do that from 22 to 52
you're going to be a multi-millionaire
wow thank you I appreciate the advice
and I am really definitely gonna try my
absolute best not to take out a single
loan and because that's what I always
wanted to do yeah and you can Anthony
like it's not like you're trying to go
pay for 30 000 right of per semester or
something like this is doable this is so
so doable go watch The Borrowed future
documentary too that'll be really
encouraging and get on a budget Anthony
um Allison will pick up we'll give you a
free trial of Ramsay Plus or of um every
dollar plus because that's going to help
you spend with your friends and enjoy it
where you're not feeling guilty about it
and to be able to say hey where can I
cut some stuff to make this tuition goal
love it we're cheering you on man we
love seeing students graduate completely
debt free that is a major key to
Building Wealth and you are on the path
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz hey if
you're a fan of the show which I assume
you are if you're taking the time to
listen to us right now we would love for
you to subscribe to the show to follow
wherever you're listening leave her a
review be kind and share it with a
friend who might enjoy this show if
they're looking for some hope in their
life and their money we so appreciate
that that is how we spread the word and
create more impact all right let's take
some more calls here triple eight eight
two five five two two five is the number
Emma is in San Bernardino Emma welcome
to the Ramsay show
thanks for having me on sure what's your
question
um so my husband is a real estate agent
and he's been with a company for about
three years now
but his boss
um is very inappropriate he's had about
three lawsuits against him for sexual
harassment
he only hires employees who are under
the age of 25 and blonde and skinny
uh is his boss Leonardo DiCaprio
this is wild
yeah and he makes really inappropriate
comments about women and he recently had
an affair with an employee and the
employee got mad at him for whatever
reason and sent out a huge email to tons
of different lenders and other agents
and just basically saying don't hire
these people don't work with them
and I don't really want my husband to be
with this company anymore because of his
boss and I mean how does your husband
feel what's your husband say about all
this
um he kind of I mean we haven't really
talked too much I think right now
because my husband's making good money I
don't know if he will really be open to
that but I'm I'm worried he's
something major is going to happen soon
oh my gosh it feels like like you want
to stay in the band on the Titanic
because of the money but we can see it
sinking
yeah that's that's the perfect way to
put it so I think he needs to see the
writing on the wall going this guy's got
multiple lawsuits again some people are
trying to actively take him down the
money may be good now but number one at
what cost
of your soul and sticking around with a
guy of this level of integrity and then
number two going this money may not be
around a year from now as word gets
around in the real estate world
yes he on like a certain is he on a
certain commission system because if
it's like with a company or a brokerage
can he
just change
brokerages yeah I mean he's had other uh
agencies reach out to him because he is
a really good yeah he sells a lot and
that's usually most of the time that's
where you're gonna find that you make
the money as a real estate agent is you
not necessarily the company now granted
there are some more companies that will
put marketing dollars behind you and all
of that but uh but he's the secret sauce
your husband so regardless of where he
got where he goes he'll be able to
perform and yeah continue to make great
money so my big thing Emma is I would
talk I mean I would be talking to him
about it
and uh just make your feelings clear I'm
not comfortable with you working around
because of his Integrity like the guy is
a creep and it's like if he's a creep
with other people like I'm like oh I
don't know if you just don't want to be
around that and is he doing weird
business like usually when you have a
lack of Integrity in one area of your
life sometimes it spills into other
areas so I would even I would just be
worried from this guy's not even trying
to hide it from like a cultural
standpoint it's really toxic but then
also who knows what he's doing behind
the scenes with yeah this is like to
keep the Leo and Titanic references
going
yeah yeah I mean they've had their place
vandalized because he slept with a
married woman who was an employee and
her husband found out so like three guys
he hired and came and just broke window
so yeah so so we yeah so the boss is one
thing right but it's you and your
husband that need to make this decision
and so that's what I want to focus on
and so the fact that you haven't brought
it up to him yet or that it hasn't been
a conversation
um yeah I mean I I that that's more of a
like a okay here's what's in my control
is hey I can actually whatever the boss
decides to do with his life that's his
issue but my issue here is that my
husband is part of a company that is
obviously just a complete they're not
jumping on the Lifeboat at all anytime
soon keeping the references going you're
welcome so Emma I would put your life
best on put the life vest on and let's
find him another job he's a fantastic
real estate agent and that is the common
denominator here not this magical agency
that's about to go under and talk to
your husband about it and the fact that
you haven't yet I'm like hmm I mean I
don't know it's yeah if it bothered me
enough to call a national radio show
it's going to bother me enough to have a
conversation with my spouse yeah so have
that conversation Emma for sure all
right let's move on to Minneapolis
Minnesota Jeremy joins us there Jeremy
welcome to the show
hey George and Rachel how are you doing
great you sound defeated Jeremy have you
just been waiting on the line too long
oh my gosh
uh let's see when did I start well I'm
central time so I started around two so
I've been doing about an hour and a half
but not bad so sorry
we really appreciate the marathon you
really you really stuck it out there
thanks my admin will be sending you a
bill so it's okay
so I have more of a money uh etiquette
question
[Applause]
um so my wife and I when we go out to
eat we usually pay cash
and
so let's say like uh this was a couple
nights ago we were at Olive Garden and
our bill was 45 30.
I leave three twenties on the table
server comes over and to me I just kind
of assume like you know what it's kind
of High they'll probably just as soon to
bring change well they go to uh just
taken they start like okay have a good
night they take it
and I'm like wait I'm like you're
bringing change right and then she got
very kind of visually upset at us and
this has happened more than you would
think when we go out to eat like just
constantly servers kind of assume
whatever money is on the table I guess
they just keep so all you gotta do
Jeremy yeah all you gotta do is say hey
uh here's 60 bucks
um can I have some change please like do
you just be proactive so that they're
not that they're not wondering right or
just tell them exactly how much change
you want back oh you could do that too
but like hey we bring yeah
that's fair so one
so one different uh place and so our
bill was like let's say it's 35 and we
had two two twenties and or maybe three
twenties so we can't give them the 40
and just say keep because it's five
bucks kind of lame
um and so then we gave them 60 and we're
like okay can you break up this 20 for
us so we can leave a tip for you he's
like okay so then he came back with
change so let's just say it was 35 we
give him 60. I would expect to get 25
back
but then they came back with like a ten
and two ones
and it sounds like they're just not good
at math
well they're just factoring they're
manipulating the the cash system to
bring you back a certain bill so that
you leave the 10 bill you can't you know
basically yeah I mean
it's yeah either in the situation you
just ask specifically what you need
um and I know you said yeah change but
say like can I have two fives like you
got to just be really you could just be
really specific or just leave them an
extra five dollars yeah well that's what
we did with the other kids we're like
you know what we don't care about this
this is a really silly uh solution but
you could just get smaller bills and
just have those on you when you're out
to eat
that's an option I do that for my
haircut so this is a great example I pay
cash for my haircuts to get to get a
discount I just went today and I go to
the bank next door and I'll break the
20. I'll get a ten five and five ones so
that I can give him exact the exact
amount with tip included
you don't know how much you're gonna
you're gonna pay for the meal of course
but the idea here is you've got you've
got a five you've got someone options
you've got some options yeah I could
when we started doing this I was like
carrying hundreds with us and then I was
like okay this is Jeremy's balling out
at Olive Garden I love it yeah but um
but so like but the problem is I just I
feel very uh uh not I don't want to say
the bad don't don't be shamed yeah don't
be ashamed
we feel very shamed that's a good way to
put it yeah because you're asking for
change back they look at it like oh he's
so cheap he doesn't want to leave us 15
bucks oh right and it's like I hate I
absolutely hate being manipulated so
it's more of that case yeah I would be
proactive and say exactly what you need
back communicate up front yep and then
as soon as they walk up to the table
there issue Jeremy as long as you're
tipping well you know 15 20 25 if it's
great
there's nothing to be ashamed about and
that's there I mean at that point and
servers love cash tips so they should be
grateful that they're not having to wait
to get that you know at the end of the
month in a check so you're doing the
right thing man don't do that right
Jeremy or don't release the shame yes
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
I'm George Campbell joined by Rachel
Cruz this hour this is the Ramsay show
listen paying off debt is smart we know
that saving and investing very smart but
there's one key to winning with money
that people Overlook all the time and
that is protecting your finances from
emergencies that's where insurance comes
into play now there are 10 kinds of
insurance coverage you might need based
on what your life looks like today and
our team has built a tool called the
coverage checkup to show you exactly
which types you need to add drop or
adjust we'll even rank your coverage
list by importance we'll email it to you
and we'll connect you with Ramsay
trusted insurance providers so you can
get your plan in place fast seriously
this could be the most important five
minutes you spend today
Donald wrote in I like how he puts it
for anyone who has not completed this
checkup do it now you never know when
something will happen and you never want
to leave your family in a bad situation
visit ramseysolutions.com checkup to use
that coverage checkup tool that's
ramseysolutions.com
checkup don't let an emergency sneak up
on you protect your family now this is
one of those areas Rachel where people
go well I'm good I I don't need
insurance everything's good right now oh
gosh yeah you need it for the what ifs
in life to protect the wealth that
you're building that's exactly right yep
very very important part of your
financial picture huge I love talking
about insurance not only because I'm a
nerd but because it's so important and
it can tank you financially if you don't
have the right ones in place
all right let's go to the phones Sarah
joins us in Ireland oh my goodness this
might be my first call from Ireland
Sarah welcome
hello I'm sorry to be the point but I'm
Italian just living in Ireland I could
listen to you all day Sarah but
unfortunately we don't have all day but
we're excited to take your call
so my problem with me is that I've been
working abroad my whole life so I could
never get into a 401k so I had a or uh
like European version of a 401k so right
now I'm just investing in basically an
SNP fund that has been treated as my
basically retirement fund but now that
I'm stable in Ireland I'm thinking about
starting the Irish 401k and I was
wondering if it's wise to take out the
investment in the s p fund that I've
been making to use as a down payment for
a home
how much is in there
it's around twenty five thousand dollars
right now the market is not doing super
hot so not that much but okay and I
would have liked to keep it there for
retirement but since I can't start on a
401K now I'm rethinking that
how old are you
I'm 34. okay and what other money do you
have do you have any money in savings
and cash
I have around like 30 000 Euros so let's
say like 35
000 more or less and then this 20 000 so
around like 60 000 but I want to keep a
very healthy emergency fund and then I'm
getting married soon so that's kind of
exciting yeah yeah thank you that's
awesome and there's zero death in the
picture at all okay and that's never
gonna so you have no debt and a giant
emergency fund and you have this
investment
yes and when you get married when is
that Sarah when's the wedding
uh it's gonna be in July in July okay
and then are you guys gonna buy a house
then together is that what is that what
the plan is
we're thinking about renting because
he's Japanese and then Italian so we
have to like scope out the town yeah so
we think about renting for a year good
yes and yeah and then buying there okay
but you were asking to cash out the
Investments for a down payment if that
if that is wise or should they just use
the the cash but then like the wedding
is gonna have some costs and then in
college like full time while working
full-time so I'm not very comfortable
using more than 10 000 of that money
because like you never know what's gonna
happen well it's great that you're being
conservative with this that will serve
you well in the future so I'm wondering
can you just cash out all of the money
in those Investments and use it towards
your future and maybe put it in like a
high yield savings account
or some version of that to protect it
because the problem is what if you rent
for a year and all of a sudden the
market is down when you need that money
for the down payment that's what worries
me yeah that's exactly that's that's
exactly what's happening now because I
was thinking right it used to be much
higher and now of course with the
downturn yeah it's it should be around
30 000 it is 25 so I was thinking
I don't want to time the market because
it's definitely like not something like
well and since you never do don't need
the cash right now I almost George would
just leave it in the s p and just let it
because I mean it's getting better like
we're seeing upticks so just leaving it
in because also Sarah I would say you
have a lot of life change happening in
the next year like you said you're going
to be in school you're getting married I
mean there's just a lot happening and
you guys may look up and two years and
be transferred somewhere else and you
may not eat this may not even be a
discussion you know so so in my in my
mind because there are so many life
changes that are going to be happening I
would George just leave it in the s p
and just let it ride out
um and then when you're really serious
okay we we know we're going to be here
we want to look to buy a house in the
next six months that's probably then
when I would remove the money and put it
in a high yield savings when you at when
when you're actually ready to buy right
it's still a little bit of a theory
right now and you just never know what
life is going to throw at you guys
because there's a a lot of change
happening yeah that could be a year and
a half away and so let's see what the
market does but you don't need the money
right now which is a great problem to
have or you can just let it sit there
yeah
all right so I guess I'll just let it
sit there and then I would yeah and then
when the house conversation becomes
actually like a reality that you're
looking out and say okay great we've
been running for a year we found the
house we want all of that then that's
when I would look to pull the money out
and hopefully you've broke even by then
or even made a little yeah for sure on
those Investments so thank you for the
call all the way from Ireland how cool
is that and next up let's go to my old
Hometown Boston Massachusetts Marianne
joins us there what's going on Marianne
hello thanks for taking my call
absolutely what's going on
so I had a question so I found out about
the Dave Ramsey plan in around like 2020
you know during the pandemic and
everything
um so obviously you know in the
beginning I was all gung-ho went hard
and then I um I became Dave ish
um and so I did stop contributing to my
401k at that point
um like you know when I found out about
everything and so I kind of spent the
last year and a half not really working
hard towards the debt and also was not
contributing so now I just started a new
job and I was kind of you know I started
contributing again because I feel like
oh no I lost like the last two years but
I still do have this pile of debt that
I'm still working on and so I was kind
of wondering your opinion on you know
should I still hold off on all the
contributions or if I should just
um you know or if I can contribute
basically
so why are you doing this plan
because I want to pay off my debt and
what's been holding you back when you
said I kind of went David I kind of got
a little you know lackadaisical with it
um I well you know it's
um
I don't know like it's just
a lot of things come up and I just don't
I you know I'm not like the best planner
I guess and
um I don't know it's a very it's a very
big struggle like I want so badly to
like get rid of my debt but then at the
same time like I
apply stuff
and that that there lies the key you
have to want to pay off the debt more
than you want the stuff how much you
have left Marianne to pay off
um I have about like 80 000 with student
loans
um yeah the payoff I've already paid off
like 30 or maybe more great job yeah
what's your income yeah
um so now I I make 150 a year heck yeah
um yeah my new my new job really brought
gave me a good bump so that's also where
like what motivated me to go back to it
you know and say like okay I really have
to like I have no excuses you know right
and how old are you
um so I'm 35 and I have I'm single but
have a have a child and how much are you
investing what percent
so it's pretty low I think I'd put it at
like four percent
um and then we also have like the profit
sharing
um and I already have about 75k in
retirement from previous jobs because
you're going to be fine for retirement I
would pause it pause it four percent of
150 000 is a heck of a lot of money yeah
that could be going towards the debt and
get you free faster and you're young you
still have time you will catch up by
funding 15 of your income after you pay
off this debt and you have some savings
so I would spend a year and a half of
just like gung-ho throwing everything at
this debt and you can you could be out
you could be out in a year and a half so
do that and then you can press play on
retirement and that all will be behind
you you're closer than you think
Marianne this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm George
Campbell joined by Rachel Cruz our
scripture of the day comes from Matthew
5 16. in the same way let your light
shine before others so that they may see
your good works and give glory to your
father who is in heaven Mark Twain once
said let us Endeavor to live so that
when we die even the Undertaker will be
sorry
love that the wittiest guy of the 19th
century I got to tell you I love Mark
Twain he was speaking in tweets before
Twitter was a thing that's right that's
right love it all right let's get back
to the phones that's where we can serve
you best Stephen joins us in Canada
Stephen welcome to the Ramsay show
hey guys thank you for taking my call
sure what's going on
yeah I just wanted to get you guys
opinion on whether or not I should
invest in a tool for my side hustle oh
okay tell us about it
yeah so I started a wood shop like a
woodworking business and I make tabletop
accessories for RPG games like Dungeons
and Dragons
Pathfinder and you can use these tools
like for Monopoly and other games as
well cool and my service items I'll just
started making a profit recently so we
are averaging 50 to 75 dollars a month
uh in profit this is a net
and I wanted to get a tool to take it to
the next level
um and this tool is approximately four
thousand dollars and I wanted to know
yeah and I wanted to know if now would
be an appropriate attempt to invest in
this uh considering I'm paying off a
little bit of debt right now okay that
was my question what is the purpose of
the side hustle my inkling is that
you're not going to Roi on that four
thousand dollar purchase enough to
Warrant it while you're in debt
so I I did a little bit of calculations
and this is kind of where I want to get
you guys opinion because I know in the
pasture Dave said the only exception is
if you can show the jar Roi is going to
be sufficient enough to pay it off in a
reasonable amount of time
so you'd be paying cash for this right
yes okay so uh I currently make 7000 a
month after tax and my total expenses
are three thousand a month uh so this
month if I don't make any payments
towards my debt I would have enough cash
to pay off pay for this total cash
how much debt do you have
56 000 in a line of credit
line of credit and how much with this
new tool will you be able to bring in
yeah so on the low end I wrote a little
bit budget analysis and on the low end
this tool should increase my profits to
buy 350 or 400 a month and that's on a
minimum the more expected amount that I
expected to bring in is 450 to 700 a
month
hmm even at 400 a month let's say 400 a
month that's still 10 months just to
break even on it and is this going to be
kind thanks Steven for you or is it just
a side hustle to get out of debt
honestly if everything goes well I would
love for it to be a full-time uh uh a
full-time uh job I guess yeah I would
love to take it on full time that's my
goal
I just have reservations with the idea
that it's guaranteed that you're going
to make 400 bucks extra a month in
profit that's the part that worries me
because what happens if it only
increases your profit by 50 to 100 bucks
a month
yeah so I was I was thinking about that
and
um what I what I saw is let's say you
know the business makes no more money
and I just shut it down right like
inside also this would um this would
increase my line of credit by one more
month because I would have to take one
month's worth of uh difference to pay up
for the tool cash and I was wondering is
that are you saying you'd use the line
of credit to do this
I've moved houses stupidly and I took a
line of credits for the difference
um in front of the office as soon as
possible okay so with my current salary
the difference between my expenses and
my income is four thousand and so if I
uh take the difference for one month I
can pay this tool okay I just wonder if
you're better off using that four grand
to throw at the debt instead of throwing
at the tool for the side Hustle
if that would get you debt-free faster
to me that's a more guaranteed rate of
return than the hopes that this picks up
which I want this thing to pick up I
just wonder if we invest in it once
we're debt free if you want to continue
it and use this as a full-time gig one
day
for sure no that makes sense the the
only reason why I thought about
purchasing this tool is right now with
one product where we we just got our
profits at 75 and we're this month and
next month we're projected to make over
200 and then this would kind of so this
is just an increase in who who's we when
you say we is it a partner or is a
spouse no no no it just it's just me I
just use we when I talk to customers and
I just kind of have the habit now okay
are you saying 200 a month
is that what you were saying okay so
yeah right now we're making of 75 to 200
a month it depends on the month I just
think you can do better with side houses
I know Stephen that like you could go
work a retailer and make more than that
right so I just don't want you to
conflate the side hustle with this is my
ticket and this is my passion right like
obviously you love this and you want to
be your full-time gig uh which is great
but I I mean honestly Stephen my number
one goal is to get completely debt free
as fast as possible and this doesn't
feel like the fastest pathway versus
driving Uber and waiting tables or what
you know like you're going to be making
more money doing something else and then
you could look up in two years
press play on this passion project save
up you know you know then buy this
invest in this tool and then if it kind
of actually starts picking up steam then
maybe you jump careers even into this
you know into this new thing but I
wouldn't use this side hustle
um for getting out of debt because it
doesn't feel lucrative right now for the
sole purpose of just getting out of debt
I understand you love it and it's your
passion but that's more of I would put
it more in the bucket of a hobby uh it's
still such a small part of your overall
income yeah it doesn't I mean if it was
two grand a month that's one thing but
just 200 at the full brand is a big
investment as well yeah but not and not
and not bring it in as much I mean like
not bringing it in a lot so well sorry
sorry Stephen I didn't want to burst the
bubble there it sounds really cool I
hope one day we'll be like that guy's a
billionaire now with his RPG tabletop
accessory
he's a smart guy all right let's try to
sneak in one more here from Jalen in
Dayton Jalen get right to the question
we're up against the clock
all right
hey
thank you for taking my call absolutely
all right so my name is Jalen I make
about 900 a month
um my college is free and I'm getting a
car from my grandpa so I don't have to
worry about that either
um so I guess I'm just wondering what
should I do with my money since I don't
really have any debt and I don't have
anything important to put towards it in
the next couple years that's great when
how old are you
I'm 18. I just turned 18 months ago good
for you Jalen okay exciting so what an
amazing gift you've been given I mean no
you know yeah college is paid for do you
have any expenses that you're gonna have
to be in charge of
um unless my parents decide to charge me
200 a month while I'm living with them
during college I don't think so okay
yeah that's great like gas and your car
insurance and all that maintenance
um gas yeah probably gas and stuff but I
don't have any like I'm not planning on
buying a house immediately I'm going to
be living with my parents while I'm
going through college for a couple years
that's great so really I mean at your
stage of Life Jalen the best thing you
can do is just I would open up a a high
yield savings account and put your money
there as you're saving have a checking
account know what your expenses are per
month so know how much you're paying in
gas if you're going out with friends you
know create a budget to know okay every
month here's my expenses and here's how
much I need out of that 900 to live off
of anything else I would put in a high
yield savings account and just let it
grow I mean it's not gonna grow a lot
right now it's like three four percent
uh but you have that money that you can
get to it and then throughout College
that's all I would do because your
number one goal is to get through school
debt free and if you can graduate with a
surplus
yes having cash I mean that's what's
incredible so and then when you graduate
you can use that money as an emergency
fund you can use that money maybe for a
down payment on a home if you're looking
to buy a home you could use that money
to start investing but I wouldn't do any
of those steps Jalen until I was out of
college so are you doing a four-year
degree or a two-year
um I'm going to be doing a two-year
degree I'm planning on going into travel
nursing and then that's going to take a
year of experience and once I get
through that I should be able to bake
about three thousand dollars a week
congratulations Jalen well done well
done yep so I would just open up a high
yield savings account and put your money
there that you're saving for let's say
500 bucks out of the 900 after expenses
that's six grand a year so even after
two years you got 12 Grand in the bank
yeah plus interest and then from there
you wouldn't worry about like saving for
an apartment and all that yet until
afterwards exactly yeah the sooner you
do it the better I just don't want to we
have too much time or and you're right
the sooner you do it the better but
you're doing it so early you're going to
catch up and be totally fine if you
start retirement at 22 23 years old
you're going to be way ahead of the game
so right now it's about having liquid
cash because you have transitions coming
up in your life after you graduate and
you move you start a new job you want
cash on hand versus it being an
investment and then Jalen you're going
to start investing around 22 23. let's
go and that's where it gets fun so well
done thank you all right that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show in the books my
thanks to my co-host Rachel Cruz all the
folks in the booth and new America until
next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]